في موسكو دعانا ابو رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسيه الى زياده عدد افراد الجيش الروسي
الى مليون ونصف مليون جندي واشار الى ان
الجيش المختلط القائمه على اساس التجنيد
والتعاقد هو الاكثر ملائمه لروسيا
[موسيقى]
اولا نحن بحاجه حاليا الى جيش مختلط قائم
على اساس التجنيد والتعاقد للدفاع عن
وطننا بنجاح ثانيا العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه اثرت بشكل كبير على جيشنا فقوه
الجيش تختبر خلال العمليات العسكريه ثالثا
لابد لجيشنا يصبح اكبر وان لا يقل عن
مليون ونصف مليون شخص
من جانبه طلب رئيس مجلس الدوما الروسي
بتعديل القانون بما يمنع اي نشاط للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه في روسيا كما دعى رئيس
مجلس الدوما الى معاقبه كل من يساعد او
يدعم المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه في روسيا